Insects have long been a staple food in Asia..
in Europe, not so much.
But diets are changing, with ever more people
trying to avoid meat – for health or moral
reasons, or because raising farm animals is
less and less sustainable.
Today, the European Commission has officially
declared mealworms to be food.. it’s a game
changer for insect farmers, many of whom have
so far operated under temporary license.
They are now hoping to grow their business
and for YOU to eat mealworms every once in
a while.. as just another source of protein.
Our reporter Lars Halter went to one of Germany’s
largest insect farms.. he sent us this report.
Schnürpflingen.. a little town in Southern
Germany, not far from where the Danube river
starts its long journey East.. there’s a
small church, and fields as far as the eye
can see.
And here is where you can catch a glimpse
of the future of our food.
And these guys have nothing to do with it.
No, we're looking at another source of protein..
and it's coming from this rather nondescript
place: two huge factory buildings.. the farm
is called Six Feet to Eat... and they’re
raising mealworms here.
These tiny insects, just over 2 centimeters
long, could be key to feeding the planet.
Insects are rich in protein.. up to 70 percent
of their entire mass in protein.
In addition to that, they're also rich in
healthy Omega-3 fatty acids.. like fish..
except with fish you have a 2 percent share
of Omega-3 fatty acids, and some insects,
especially the mealworm, have over 14 percent..
that's seven times as much.
Literally millions of insects are being raised
here.. mealworms, crickets, grasshoppers...
each breed with very particular needs... like
steady temperatures of up to 40 degrees.
The insects live for just four to five weeks..
before they make their way into a fridge,
fall into a deep sleep that ends in a roasting
oven.
They’re packaged… and sent to stores,
restaurants or straight to consumers.. who
are currently paying premium for the product.
But with the EU paving the way, the company
hopes to produce cheaper soon.
There are some insects that are ideally suited
for ethical factory farming.. like the mealworm
or the cricket.
We're currently establishing some level of
automation in our processes to get away from
a lot of the manual labor that's currently
needed.
That is a way to cut cost and it will help
bring consumer prices down, too.
But what about those who can’t stomach a
bug on their salad or pasta dish?
Well, they can go to the Nürnbäcker.
Kurt Heinlein is a baker in Nürnberg and
he has been specializing in interesting ingredients..
like spelt.. or, well, insects.
His insect bread contains 20 percent mealworm
flower.. it's pricey.. at over 8 Euro for
a small loaf.. but customers have quickly
taken an interest.
We were positively surprised.. especially
with regards to our older customers.
We thought that the younger generation would
be more likely to try out something new..
but in fact it was the over-fifty group that
got really excited about it.. and many even
tried the whole mealworms, too
Reason enough for the baker to hope that his
store stays busy.. and customers are enjoying
more of his experiments.